das ist sehr spannend bewusst wurde wir
haben eigentlich immer viel schnee das
waren nie so thema das wir jetzt dass
die neuen top jetzt us down kind dazu
gehört das down wie lara blome 3 ist
das mitglied der auch mit dem bundesheer
das hätte man denkt
saurier pilot damit man es überhaupt
kein problem
das kind seine mama tanja erster flug
für die lauer
hoffentlich stärkt sie wird mit ihrer
umgang man ja das ist ja das nächste
bundeswehr haben wir mit kindle store
wie ging es mit ihrer um die lage sehr
sensibles kind der messe köln sondern
die lauer einigung das war alles zu
schnell gegangen ist aber trotzdem sehr
liebevoller umgang heute sehr
professionell
[Musik]
sievert und physik senken und das ist
wohl wahr und das immer irgendwann gerät
wird mit ihrer 3
[Musik]
sie wollen es nicht sagt es kommt eben
sie es oft kämpfen
[Musik]
und dann ist didier aufgegangen
dufry ist die macher dass dies endlich
wieder bei dir horst simon tage seien zu
lange
es ist wieder so hundt
das so gut und gomez hatte nie vor
sommer ich doch mal danke
[Musik]